I'm Jo and I work as an assistant practitioner in a CAM service in Lancashire. I bought and read Marianne's book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to accompany me while completing the clinical psychology training application. It proved to be really good company. I found it sparked ideas of how to build experience and skills, but more than that, it offered the chance to get lost in people's stories. It provided a timely reminder not to get so cold, up in an end goal and to value and enjoy each job we fulfil along the way because the work we do now is important and matters to those we sit alongside as well as ourselves. It also gave the reassurance that there are eclectic roots into clinical psychology which is important for me as someone who's had a meandering journey and not a typical route to the profession. I wholeheartedly
我是Jo，我在兰开夏郡的一家心理健康服务机构担任助理医师。我购买并阅读了玛丽安的书《临床心理学家集体》，以此陪伴我完成临床心理学培训的申请。事实证明，它确实是一个很好的伙伴。我发现它激发了我关于如何积累经验和技能的想法，但更重要的是，它让我有机会沉浸在人们的故事中。它及时提醒我，不要太冷漠，不要只盯着最终目标，而要珍惜并享受我们一路走来的每一份工作，因为我们现在所做的工作很重要，对我们身边的人以及我们自己都有意义。它还让我确信，通往临床心理学的道路是多元的，这对我来说很重要，因为我走过一段曲折的旅程，并不是进入该行业的典型路线。我衷心
recommend the book for both personal and professional reasons. Be prepared to put evening tasks on hold for a while though because once you've started reading it's tough to put it down. We like to think we're modern humans but our brains didn't get that update. They're still wired for caves, threat and survival, not smartphones, deadlines and self-actualization. And that mismatch? Well that's why so many of us feel anxious, overwhelmed or like we're failing at modern life. In today's episode I'm chatting with fellow clinical psychologist Dr. Matt Slavin and we're discussing how and why your ancient brain behaves in the way it does and how understanding it might just change everything you know about your mental health. Hope you find it super useful
推荐这本书，无论是出于个人还是职业原因。不过，请做好准备，暂时搁置晚上的任务，因为一旦开始阅读，就很难放下了。我们喜欢认为自己是现代人类，但我们的大脑并没有进行那种更新。它们仍然是为了洞穴、威胁和生存而设计的，而不是为了智能手机、截止日期和自我实现。而这种错位呢？这就是为什么我们许多人感到焦虑、不知所措，或者觉得自己无法过好现代生活的原因。在今天的节目中，我将与临床心理学家同事马特·斯莱文博士聊天，我们将讨论你的古老大脑为何以及如何以这种方式运作，以及理解它可能会改变你对心理健康的所有认知。希望你觉得它非常有用
and if you do please like and subscribe for more. Welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast. I am joined today by Dr. Matt Slavin. Hi Matt, thanks for joining us. Hi, everyone. Thank you for being here. Can you tell us why it matters that we've got these kind of old brains? Can't we just go about and live our lives? Why does it matter that we know about all of this stuff?
如果你觉得有用，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。欢迎来到“有抱负的心理学家”播客。今天和我在一起的是马特·斯莱文博士。你好，马特，感谢你的加入。大家好。谢谢你们在这里。你能告诉我们，为什么我们拥有这种“古老的大脑”很重要吗？我们难道不能就这样过我们的生活吗？了解所有这些东西有什么意义呢？
Well, does it matter? I think it's one of the most important things to remember. We'd like to think that we're finally evolved creatures who turn up in shirts and jumpers. but that's not what our brains are convinced of. It's not what your nervous system is convinced of. It's definitely not what your well-being and your mental health and your frame of aspirations are made of.
嗯，这重要吗？我认为这是最需要记住的事情之一。我们喜欢认为自己是最终进化的生物，穿着衬衫和毛衣，但我们的大脑并不这么认为。你的神经系统也不这么认为。你的幸福感、心理健康和抱负框架绝对不是由这些构成的。
We can't help but escape that we're driven by all these ancient drives and they still drive us. And this is the challenge we talked about to come on the podcast about is that we have an ancient brain designed for an ancient world and yet we're in a modern day world. And so a huge amount of difficulty, challenge, comes up when these two worlds come together. Yeah, absolutely they do.
我们无法逃避这样一个事实：我们受到所有这些古老驱动力的驱使，它们仍然在驱动着我们。这就是我们讨论要上播客的挑战，即我们拥有一个为古代世界设计的大脑，但我们却生活在现代世界。因此，当这两个世界碰撞时，就会产生大量的困难和挑战。是的，绝对是这样。
Could you give us a few of the kind of urges that we might be having that might come from our ancient brain that maybe not marrying up so well in 2025 and beyond? One thing I often do when I do a training with a team is that I talk them through our ancient ancestry and how we've come to be here today. And I think it's important to remember that life, as we know it, has been around on this planet for around 4 billion years. So a pretty long time. And I walk this out, actually.
你能给我们举几个我们可能有的、来自古老大脑的冲动吗？这些冲动在2025年及以后可能不太适用了。我经常在给团队做培训时做的一件事，就是向他们讲述我们的古代祖先以及我们是如何走到今天的。我认为重要的是要记住，我们所知的生命在这个星球上已经存在了大约40亿年。所以时间相当长。我实际上会演示这一点。
I get like a 10 metre piece of land. I often do it out in nature. And I walk a meter. And every meter I tell a different part of that story. And it's only in the 10 meters. It's only in that last blade of grass, the very end, that humans came to be on this planet around 250,000 years ago. And then in that, we have to divide the blade of grass into micropoints to get to where we had the Industrial Revolution,
我会找一块10米长的地。我经常在户外做这个。我走一米。每一米我都讲述那个故事的不同部分。而在10米中，只有在最后一片草叶上，也就是最末端，人类才在25万年前出现在这个星球上。然后，我们必须把那片草叶分成微小的点，才能到达我们经历工业革命的地方，
and then we had smartphones, and then we have this modern tech that we live in. So ancient drives. Really important to remember that for the majority of our history, we have been around for survival, not for success. And so our brains and our bodies and our nervous system do three wonderful things all the time. They're trying to avoid danger. They're trying to find resources and they're trying to pass on our genetic code. Everything else we would say is just extra. Nice stuff. So one of the great impulses we have is to stay alive. And we're not built so well for the battle of success and purpose and meaning, things we actually think that's what our life should be about. And actually what we're built for is to avoid danger and to, well,
然后我们有了智能手机，然后我们有了我们所处的现代科技。所以，古老的驱动力。非常重要的一点是，在我们的历史大部分时间里，我们是为了生存，而不是为了成功。所以我们的大脑、身体和神经系统一直在做三件美妙的事情。它们试图避免危险，试图寻找资源，并试图传递我们的基因密码。其他一切我们都会说是额外的。好东西。所以我们拥有的伟大冲动之一就是活下去。我们并不太适合成功、目标和意义的战斗，我们实际上认为生活应该围绕这些展开。而实际上我们是为了避免危险而生的，并且，嗯，
here's the thing. This is what it comes into mental health is we try and avoid discomfort. Because our brains are so unbelievably clever. But the one thing they're not very clever at is distinguishing truth from imagined truth. So we can get into a whole bunch of tricky tricky grounds our tricky brain as a friend might call it is that we get into to the realms of trying to avoid emotional discomfort trying to run away from negative feelings we put that word negative before any emotions unpleasant feelings but the very thing of doing that often means that we don't get to where we want to go in life so one of the great impulses is to avoid the very thing we want which is the pursuit of ambitions aims successes because the path is
问题就在这里。这就是它进入心理健康领域的原因，我们试图避免不适。因为我们的大脑聪明得令人难以置信。但它们不太擅长的一件事是区分真相和想象中的真相。所以我们可能会陷入一大堆棘手的领域——正如朋友可能称之为“棘手的大脑”——那就是我们进入了试图避免情感不适、试图逃避负面情绪的领域，我们在任何情绪之前加上“负面”这个词，即不愉快的感觉，但这样做往往意味着我们无法达到我们想要的生活目标，所以伟大的冲动之一就是避免我们真正想要的东西，即追求抱负、目标、成功，因为这条路
always inevitably going to be filled with unpleasant feelings, stress, doubt, uncertainty. They are part of the course and yet they're the things we try to avoid because they are very uncomfortable. Yes, indeed they are. There's a really lovely book by Dr Chris Irons as well about kind of compassion-focused therapy and difficult feelings. It's a really nice one. But I'm guessing, kind of as I hear you talk, if Maslow and his hierarchy had been around earlier, that would have looked quite different because it sounds like the self-actualization phase, which goes at the top of Maslow's hierarchy, is actually a very much more modern bolt on and really would have just been looking at those bottom layers, right? We're so privileged. Now, I have to frame this in context. We're so privileged in particular parts of the world, in particular socioeconomic demographics, that there are, I'm very lucky to say that I'm not worried most days about surviving. Most days I've got a shelter over my head. I'm probably thinking what food choices I'm going to have as opposed to whether I'm going to eat or not. And so many of us, not all of us, but many of us are no longer having the battle for survival. We've almost beat the battle for survival.
总是不可避免地充满不愉快的感觉、压力、怀疑、不确定性。它们是过程的一部分，但它们却是我们试图避免的东西，因为它们非常不舒服。是的，确实如此。克里斯·艾恩斯博士也有一本关于同情心聚焦疗法和困难情绪的非常好的书。这是一本非常好的书。但我猜，当我听你说话时，如果马斯洛和他的需求层次理论早点出现，情况会大不相同，因为听起来自我实现阶段，也就是马斯洛层次的顶端，实际上是一个非常现代的附加物，而原本可能只是关注那些底层，对吧？我们太幸运了。现在，我必须在背景中说明这一点。我们在世界上的特定地区、特定的社会经济人口统计中非常幸运，我很幸运地说，我大多数日子里不用担心生存问题。大多数日子里我有遮风挡雨的地方。我可能在想我要选择什么食物，而不是我是否能吃上饭。所以我们许多人，不是所有人，但我们许多人不再为生存而战。我们几乎已经赢得了生存之战。
If anything, we're trying to prolong survival. Let's stay really around for a very long period of life. But as you say, it's really recent. You only have to go back, if we even go back 50 years in the UK before the NHS, it's a bit longer than 50 years, 1950, 40, something. when the NHS were founded, that we didn't have all access to medicine, to medicine, to shelter, to survival, that actually it's only been 70 years, really we've got access to healthcare as we know it, go 100 years back, mortality rates are much, much higher, 200 years back, it's a very different world we live in. And yet nothing has changed in our neurocircuitary.
如果说有什么的话，我们是在试图延长生存。让我们在很长一段时间内保持生存。但正如你所说，这真的很近。你只需要回顾一下，如果我们回顾英国NHS成立前的50年，其实比50年长一点，1950年、40年左右。当NHS成立时，我们并没有获得所有药物、医疗、住所、生存保障，实际上只有70年，我们才真正获得了我们所知的医疗保健，回顾100年前，死亡率要高得多，回顾200年前，我们生活的世界非常不同。然而我们的神经回路什么都没有改变。
Nothing's changed in our biology, our neurobiology, exactly the same as we were. Yeah, absolutely. I think our posture is getting poorer over time, and I don't know whether there will be evidence that our brains might, well, they shrink over time if we're not using certain elements. That's the whole chat GPT stuff, isn't it? We're making ourselves more stupid. But yeah, really, really interesting food for thought. And making me think that yesterday I watched half of a Bannattenborough program that's kind of a new series at the moment about different cat tribes locally and their fight. for survival and it really does just show like how different their lives are compared to ours
我们的生物学、神经生物学什么都没有改变，和以前完全一样。是的，绝对是这样。我认为我们的姿势随着时间的推移变得越来越差，我不知道是否有证据表明我们的大脑可能会，嗯，如果我们不使用某些元素，它们会随着时间的推移而萎缩。这就是ChatGPT的全部内容，不是吗？我们正在让自己变得更愚蠢。但是的，非常、非常有意思的思考。让我想到昨天我看了半个大卫·爱登堡的节目，那是目前的一个新系列，关于当地不同的猫科部落以及它们的生存斗争，它确实展示了它们的生活与我们的生活有多么不同
but that's what ours would have been like right as well like having to find food keeping your young safe stopping tigers or lions from coming and killing our our babies like it really does put things into perspective and you know we have our lovely front drawers that we can lock and try and keep our kids safe and we've got seatbelts and and all of the this stuff, but yeah, it's a very different set of circumstances, isn't it, than where our ancestors would have been in caves, for example. Exactly. And I think it's a very compassionate view to see ourselves in this way, because it gives permission for us to say, that is how we all are, is to, for instance, to have a negativity bias, to see the worst in it. It's an evolutionary
但那也会是我们的生活，对吧？比如必须寻找食物、保护幼崽、阻止老虎或狮子来杀死我们的婴儿，这确实让事情变得清晰起来。你知道，我们有可爱的防盗门，我们可以锁上并试图保护我们的孩子，我们有安全带，还有所有这些东西，但是的，这与我们的祖先在洞穴里的情况非常不同，不是吗？正是如此。我认为以这种方式看待自己是一种非常有同情心的观点，因为它允许我们说，我们所有人都是这样的，例如，有一种负面偏见，看到事情最坏的一面。这是一种进化
adaptation, aiding survival to be, should we let's say shorthand, to be a pest. or to see the worst in things. That's useful, right? It was far more useful in caveman days to be able to see the snake in the grass or to read the impending storm or to read in the eyes of another perhaps a sense of danger foreboding. Now all of that was far more useful than be able to find honey on the trees or to celebrate success. And so our brains have been wired to really look for the worst in situations and we're pretty good at that. I'm pretty good at that nowadays. And I would say this is a learned skill that we all have to gain in life and that we're not taught in schools, that hopefully you do learn through parents. Maybe you learn through your psychology training or
适应，有助于生存，简而言之，就是变得警惕，或者看到事情最坏的一面。这很有用，对吧？在穴居人时代，能够看到草丛中的蛇，或者读懂即将来临的风暴，或者从别人的眼中读出一种危险的预感，这要有用得多。现在，所有这些都比在树上找到蜂蜜或庆祝成功要有用得多。所以我们的大脑被设定为真正寻找情况中最坏的一面，我们现在很擅长这一点。我现在很擅长这一点。我会说这是一种我们每个人在生活中都必须获得的习得技能，我们在学校里没有被教过，希望你通过父母学到。也许你通过心理学培训学到，或者
you learn through going to therapy. You learn through the wonderful world of the internet is the skills it takes to be able to catch your thinking, to know that your brain is wired to see the worst in things wired to ruminate, to have worry, to human beings. We hate uncertainty for the very reasons of our evolution, that uncertainty was unpredictability, and unpredictability meant greater chances or threat to life. So knowing all this, and now it comes from, I think, firstly, is the great compassionate view. And then there's a skill to be able to manage thought management or emotional literacy and emotional management to manage these things which are driving us to feel scared most of the time. Yeah, it's that whole negative attribution bias, isn't it?
你通过互联网这个奇妙的世界学到，这就是能够捕捉你的思维、知道你的大脑被设定为看到事情最坏的一面、被设定为反刍、有担忧的技能。人类。我们讨厌不确定性，原因正是我们的进化，不确定性意味着不可预测性，而不可预测性意味着更大的生命威胁机会。所以了解这一切，现在它来自哪里，我认为，首先是伟大的同情心视角。然后是一种能够管理思维管理或情绪素养和情绪管理的技能，以管理这些让我们大多数时间感到害怕的事情。是的，这就是整个负面归因偏见，不是吗？
Like actually we might go into a shop and have, you know, nine brilliant experiences, but it's the it's the 10th one where we feel like they've been a bit rude or something outlandish has happened. That's the one we're going to tell our friends about because when we understand the brain kind of the way that our brains have been put together, it's because that negative thing could be the thing that is a risk to ourselves, our family, our tribe. So it makes sense that that's going to be sticking up more for us to pay attention to. It can be exhausting though, can't it? To be around Eeyore types. So as it said that we're all, we're all a part of a character from Winnie the Pooh. There's a Tigger, there's E. Or there's Winnie the Pooh himself. Like being around
就像实际上我们可能会走进一家商店，有九次很棒的经历，但第十次我们觉得他们有点粗鲁或者发生了什么离谱的事情。那才是我们要告诉朋友的事情，因为当我们理解大脑以及我们大脑组合在一起的方式时，这是因为那件负面的事情可能是对我们自己、我们的家庭、我们的部落构成风险的事情。所以它更突出让我们注意是有道理的。但这可能会让人筋疲力尽，不是吗？和“屹耳”类型的人在一起。正如所说，我们都是小熊维尼中角色的一个部分。有跳跳虎，有屹耳，有小熊维尼本人。就像和
people that seem to be overly negative can be exhausting. Would we all have been like that in it originally, do you think? I don't know the answer to that. I love and I love the analogy. I think our sensory profiles and our attachment profiles very much fit into the different character tropes from Winnie the Pooh. And I grew up from the Winnie the Pooh. So I always feel a great sense of comfort reading it. And would we all be like that? Now, it's hard to know exactly what would be like. Many curious minds have thought what exactly are we like?
看起来过于消极的人在一起可能会让人筋疲力尽。你认为我们最初都会那样吗？我不知道答案。我喜欢这个类比。我认为我们的感官特征和依恋特征非常符合小熊维尼中的不同角色原型。我是看着小熊维尼长大的。所以我读它时总是感到一种巨大的安慰。我们都会那样吗？现在，很难确切知道会是什么样子。许多好奇的头脑都想过我们到底是什么样的？
What would we be like back then? Perhaps, but perhaps we could also go the other way. Perhaps we wouldn't worry as much. Perhaps part of, if we go into more acceptance and commitment therapy language, perhaps we'd be more willing to, or willing or have more acceptance of the life, this life as it is, that is very precious. sometimes understanding how fragile life is. I know personally when I've been through some of my darkest periods of my life
那时我们会是什么样？也许，但也许我们也可以走向另一个方向。也许我们不会那么担心。也许，如果我们进入更多的接纳承诺疗法语言，也许我们会更愿意，或者有更多的接纳，接纳生活，这种生活是如此珍贵。有时理解生命是多么脆弱。我知道我个人经历过我生命中最黑暗的时期
and most close to the raw elements of life, loss and hardship, that actually life somehow feels less stressful in those moments for me where you can appreciate things far more. And I think we would have been much more in contact with loss and death and suffering in a way that perhaps we wouldn't have the time to worry about it so much, either through acceptance or also, because we're not, maybe now, because many people are not fighting the fight for survival,
最接近生命原始元素、损失和苦难的时候，实际上在那些时刻，生活对我来说感觉压力较小，你可以更欣赏事物。我认为我们本来会更多地接触到损失、死亡和痛苦，以至于我们可能没有时间去担心它，无论是通过接纳，还是因为我们不是，也许现在，因为许多人不再为生存而战，
in the purest sense of the word, that we're left with a lot of time to think, and a lot of time to think about what we want from this life. And this life can be cruel and unfair, and it can mean that we can't always have all the things that we want in this life, in which case, then there's a lot of suffering, thinking about what we don't, what we wish for, where we're not yet, about the relationship, they didn't quite work out in ways that maybe these kind of worries wouldn't have been so
用这个词最纯粹的意义来说，我们剩下很多时间去思考，很多时间去思考我们想要从生活中得到什么。而这种生活可能是残酷和不公平的，这意味着我们不能总是拥有我们想要的所有东西，在这种情况下，就会有很多痛苦，思考我们没有的、我们希望的、我们还没达到的地方，关于那些没能成功的关系，也许这些担忧在更以生存为驱动的世界里不会那么
present in our mind in a more survival-driven world. Yeah, and our lives would have been so much smaller, right, because it would have just been ourselves, our families, our immediate tribes, whereas at the moment, I certainly feel as a clinical psychologist and a mother that we'll be, sometimes I'll be, sometimes I'll be really worried about people on the other side of the world that I've never met and never will meet. And that can feel like a lot. That can feel like a lot of concern for people and what it is to be human and, you know, to go through earthquakes, to go through war, to go through all of these horrendous things. And we were never, we were never designed to be able to have that
出现在我们的脑海中。是的，我们的生活会小得多，对吧？因为那将只是我们自己、我们的家庭、我们直接的部落，而目前，作为一名临床心理学家和母亲，我肯定会感到，有时我会非常担心世界另一端我从未见过也永远不会见到的人。这可能会让人感觉很多。这可能会让人对人们以及作为人类意味着什么感到非常担忧，你知道，经历地震、经历战争、经历所有这些可怕的事情。我们从来没有被设计成能够拥有那种
level of being bothered by other people were we no and it and it never stops is that we're in our household we've got very careful rules about exposure to the news we have very periodized times where we'll check in um because the news i'd say television um these things the companies the news agencies they know the one that's important to listen to what's going on in the world absolutely But they also, they will know how our brains are wired. They know the psychology of fear, and they're very good at making us hook into it. And once we see something that brings our attention to it, we'd say alerts our attention to it. And once it's alerted, then we're very concerned if something's going to be, you know, a worrying news story.
被其他人困扰的程度，不是吗？不，而且它永远不会停止，我们在家里对接触新闻有非常严格的规定，我们有非常周期性的时间来查看，因为新闻，我会说电视，这些东西，公司，新闻机构，他们知道听取世界上正在发生的事情很重要，绝对。但他们也知道我们的大脑是如何运作的。他们知道恐惧的心理学，他们非常擅长让我们沉迷其中。一旦我们看到引起我们注意的东西，我们就会说提醒我们注意它。一旦它被提醒，那么如果有什么事情要成为，你知道，一个令人担忧的新闻故事，我们就会非常担心。
It's very hard to detach from, to de-anchor from. So, yeah, in our own tribes, we probably have access to what's going on in our immediate family. family and our immediate world, but nowadays if you let yourself, or even if you don't let yourself, even if you are exposed in this modern day world, we're almost always bombarded with things that are going to alert our, definitely alert our involuntary attentional response. We've got two voluntary, we've got our voluntary and our involuntary attentional responses, voluntary what we choose to look at, the part of our brain that can focus and select and ignore information. It's the part of our attentional capacity that is susceptible
很难脱离，很难解开锚点。所以，是的，在我们的部落里，我们可能能够接触到我们直系亲属和我们直接世界中正在发生的事情，但如今，如果你让自己，或者即使你不让自己，即使你在这个现代世界中接触到，我们几乎总是被那些会提醒我们的东西轰炸，绝对会提醒我们的非自愿注意反应。我们有两种注意反应，我们有自愿和非自愿的注意反应，自愿是我们选择看什么，我们大脑中能够聚焦、选择和忽略信息的部分。它是我们注意能力中容易
for fatigue, which we're getting worse at because we're not stretching it nowadays. But the involuntary attentional pathway in our brains is always on because that's the intentional pathway that allowed us to survive. So I think about it like in our brains, we've got our mere cat brain. So we've got our mere cats constantly watching on guard and we're always scanning because if any moment, I don't know if my alarm went off downstairs, I couldn't help but hear it. My whole being would be alerted and oriented to it. And then I want to do something about responding to it.
疲劳的部分，我们现在在这方面做得越来越差，因为我们现在不锻炼它。但我们大脑中的非自愿注意通路总是开启的，因为那是允许我们生存的注意通路。所以我把它想成在我们的大脑中，我们有我们的猫鼬大脑。所以我们有猫鼬不断地在守卫，我们一直在扫描，因为如果任何时刻，我不知道如果我的警报器在楼下响了，我无法不听到它。我的整个存在都会被提醒并转向它。然后我想做点什么来回应它。
Now, I might have trained myself well enough to be able to, once I know it's not a signal of absolute fear and danger, I could then train myself to not listen to it. But the danger in our modern day world is all the pings we get from digital devices, all the way the emails pop up, all the ways that our WhatsApp notifications play, all the news stories, they're designed to hook our involuntary attention in a way that's very hard just through willpower alone to not get swept away and to be and to feel it and to be affected by it, for sure. Yeah, absolutely it is. And even though my phone's on silent,
现在，我可能已经训练自己足够好，能够，一旦我知道它不是绝对恐惧和危险的信号，我就可以训练自己不去听它。但我们现代世界的危险是所有我们从数字设备中得到的叮当声，所有电子邮件弹出的方式，所有WhatsApp通知播放的方式，所有新闻故事，它们被设计成以一种非常难以仅靠意志力而不被卷走、不被影响的方式钩住我们的非自愿注意，这是肯定的。是的，绝对是这样。即使我的手机静音了，
it's connected to my watch. So my watch will regularly alert me to things that I actually am not interested in. Like, I should probably change those alerts. I think I'm interested in your opinion on this, but the pandemic was a great level up for clinicians and people with mental health problems and the general population. So I remember very clearly being in a clinic session with a client who, this was early 2020, so this was probably January. And the client had shared with me that they were anxious about something that was going on in in China and I with hindsight was I don't know but I guess using a CBTish lens which I don't usually use but shut that down a bit really and was like oh this is not something we're going to need
它连接到我的手表。所以我的手表会经常提醒我一些我实际上不感兴趣的事情。就像，我可能应该更改那些提醒。我想听听你对此的看法，但大流行对临床医生、有心理健康问题的人和普通大众来说是一个巨大的升级。所以我清楚地记得在与一位客户进行临床会谈时，这是2020年初，所以这可能是1月。客户与我分享说，他们对中国正在发生的事情感到焦虑，而我事后看来，我不知道，但我猜是使用了我通常不使用的CBT视角，确实稍微关闭了这一点，并说，哦，这不是我们需要
to be worried about and we're going to need to just notice that as a thought and then think about how that obviously will trigger our responses but you know it's all going to be okay and actually, and I gave the client some data, you know, to add to their knowledge and said, did you know that not all people who get diagnosed with COVID die? And the client said, well, no, actually, I didn't know that. And that does make this feel less scary. But then ultimately, what unfolded in the next couple of months did really make me think about eating my words. You know, it was me who, as Boris Johnson was telling us all, that the country was going under lockdown and that the schools were being closed, I was sitting on the floor in my living
担心的，我们需要只是注意到它作为一个想法，然后思考它显然会如何触发我们的反应，但你知道，一切都会好起来的，实际上，我给了客户一些数据，你知道，增加他们的知识，并说，你知道吗，并非所有被诊断出患有COVID的人都会死？客户说，嗯，不，实际上，我不知道。这确实让事情感觉不那么可怕了。但最终，接下来的几个月里发生的事情确实让我考虑收回我的话。你知道，是我，当鲍里斯·约翰逊告诉我们所有人，国家即将封锁，学校即将关闭时，我正坐在客厅的地板上
room, on the rug, crying and really worried that my children were going to die. And that was, you know, that was a really difficult period because, of course, I was working in the NHS, so I was having to still go into work. Like, it's hard to walk into the face of day, and when actually that's not necessarily the job I signed up to. I didn't sign up to be a firefighter or to be in the walk to be an army, you know, personnel. But like, for me, that really began to break down that barrier between professionals, mental health professionals and the people we serve. And it definitely humanised the process. I think this is relevant. to what we're talking about. It feels kind of relevant. What do you think to all of that, Matt?
在地毯上，哭泣，非常担心我的孩子们会死。那是一个非常困难的时期，因为当然，我在NHS工作，所以我仍然必须去上班。就像，面对白天很难走进去，而实际上那并不一定是我签约的工作。我没有签约成为消防员或成为军队人员。但对我来说，这确实开始打破专业人士、心理健康专业人士和我们服务的人之间的障碍。它绝对使这个过程人性化了。我认为这与我们正在谈论的内容相关。感觉有点相关。你对此怎么看，马特？
Lots of thoughts. Okay, I'll respond to the last point and then I'll come back to where my brain went first of all, is that I remember doing my training and having a wonderful clinical psychologist who talked to me, we talked a lot about the philosophy of science. I found that very interesting, personally. And we talked about functional contextualism, which in essence says there's that every behaviour in this world makes sense. if you understand the right context. So all of the clients that we see, anything we bring, fear, anxiety, depression, psychosis, all of this makes sense when we think about the context it came from
很多想法。好的，我会回应最后一点，然后我会回到我大脑首先想到的地方，我记得我在接受培训时，有一位很棒的临床心理学家和我谈过，我们谈了很多关于科学哲学的问题。我个人觉得这非常有趣。我们谈到了功能语境主义，其本质是说这个世界上的每一种行为都是有意义的。如果你理解了正确的语境。所以我们看到的所有客户，我们带来的任何东西，恐惧、焦虑、抑郁、精神病，当我们思考它来自的语境时，所有这些都是有意义的
and where it's being applied. And quite commonly, I bring this in the idea of evolution as well because I think it's very helpful to remember everything where it came from. The challenge is when the function and the context don't quite fit. And I would say actually there's times where even the most inverted commas, dysfunctional, maladaptive behaviours are incredibly functional in the right context. So I don't want my surgeon to feel emotional about cutting me open. So I want them to functionally dissociate. I don't want my firefighter to go, oh, that's scary and hot. I don't want to go in there. No, I want
以及它被应用的地方。而且很常见的是，我也把进化论的想法带入其中，因为我认为记住一切来自哪里非常有帮助。挑战在于当功能和语境不太匹配时。我会说实际上有些时候，即使是最加引号的、功能失调的、适应不良的行为在正确的语境下也是非常有功能的。所以我不想让我的外科医生在切开我时感到情绪化。所以我希望他们功能性地解离。我不想让我的消防员说，哦，那很可怕，很热。我不想进去。不，我希望
them to be cold and emotionless going into the fire. Same we want for our soldiers. I think properly, I would say, my thought was probably the same for clinical psychologist that actually there's a level of emotional responsiveness you need to have and switch online. You can't be cold in a session. I don't think being a straight data-driven psychologist is the right way to do it. I once had a CAM supervisor who would say the human doesn't matter, it's all about the technique.
他们冷酷无情地走进火场。我们对士兵也希望如此。我想，我可能会说，我的想法可能对临床心理学家也是一样的，实际上你需要有一种情绪反应并开启它。你在会谈中不能冷漠。我不认为做一个纯粹的数据驱动的心理学家是正确的方法。我曾经有一位CAM主管会说，人并不重要，一切都与技术有关。
I don't agree with that. I think it's all about the relationship. But there's a part of that what we need to, sometimes we need to think about the context. How do we need to respond to that person? It's very, very subjective and it matters. That's why a good formulation matters for that person. what you need to be for that person.
我不同意这一点。我认为一切都与关系有关。但我们需要的一部分，有时我们需要思考语境。我们需要如何回应那个人？这是非常、非常主观的，而且很重要。这就是为什么一个好的构思对那个人很重要。你需要成为那个人的什么。
But if I link it back to what you said before, my practice has massively shifted over the years of having to be this, I don't know, this clinical psychologist to be a, to be Matt. And I'm far more human with my clients now. The big change for me was when I started working outdoors and I developed my outdoor nature-based practice. It's always been part of my work,
但如果我把它和你之前说的话联系起来，我的实践多年来已经发生了巨大的转变，从必须成为这个，我不知道，这个临床心理学家，变成马特。我现在对我的客户更加人性化了。对我来说，最大的改变是我开始在户外工作，我发展了我的户外自然疗法实践。它一直是我工作的一部分，
but I did, I've done more and more of that under model, under clinical models. of eco-sensory therapy, types of ways we could really work clinically in the outdoors. And their hierarchy drops away because you're not in my clinic, you're in the woods, you're out in nature. And then you're meeting two human beings
但我做了，我在模型下，在临床模型下做了越来越多。生态感官疗法，我们真正可以在户外进行临床工作的方式。他们的等级制度消失了，因为你不在我的诊所，你在树林里，你在大自然中。然后你遇到了两个人类
where we get to have conversations like you did, but the conversation changes to whether it's the right or wrong way of thinking about something, to how do you manage themes of, let's go back to the theme, the uncertainty. I don't know, And you can say, we don't know if we're going to be okay. That was the collective experience during lockdown.
我们有机会进行像你那样的对话，但对话从思考某事是对还是错，变成了你如何管理主题，让我们回到主题，不确定性。我不知道，你可以说，我们不知道我们是否会好起来。那是封锁期间的集体经历。
We don't know. So how did we manage that? How do you manage not knowing what's important to you? What do you want to prioritize? How do you manage the fear? Those themes that came up during COVID, there's still themes we're wrestling with. We'll wrestle for the rest of their lives. Who do we want to connect with and how do we connect to ourselves?
我们不知道。那么我们是如何管理的呢？你如何管理不知道什么对你重要？你想优先考虑什么？你如何管理恐惧？那些在COVID期间出现的主题，仍然是我们正在努力解决的主题。我们将为他们的余生而奋斗。我们想与谁建立联系，我们如何与自己建立联系？
How do we manage fear and suffering uncertainty? And ultimately, what do we want to do in this life and hold no regret over? Yeah, absolutely. And yeah, like I often think about my own death. I don't know that's overly morbid, but because I lost my dad in 2017. I had his kind of experience of deathbed conversations. And it's made me think about what my lasting legacy will be, both as a parent, as a clinician, as a, you know, as a mental health spokesperson as well.
我们如何管理恐惧和痛苦的不确定性？最终，我们想在这辈子做什么，并且不留遗憾？是的，绝对是这样。而且，是的，就像我经常思考我自己的死亡。我不知道这是否过于病态，但因为我在2017年失去了我的父亲。我有过他那种临终谈话的经历。这让我思考我将留下什么样的遗产，无论是作为父母、作为临床医生，还是作为，你知道，心理健康发言人。
And I would just, yeah, I would want to think there weren't any regrets and that I'd lived authentically and to serve myself but also others. And, yeah, like, again, like you said, that that is a very modern gift, isn't it, that we begin to think about, we get to think about our own mortality and to strive for what we want to have achieved rather than just, you know, eating, hunting, reproducing. Well, maybe one of the big differences nowadays is that those three core needs,
我只是，是的，我想认为没有任何遗憾，我活得真实，服务于自己也服务于他人。而且，是的，就像你说的，那是一个非常现代的礼物，不是吗？我们开始思考，我们有机会思考我们自己的死亡，并努力争取我们想要实现的成就，而不是仅仅，你知道，吃饭、狩猎、繁殖。好吧，也许现在最大的区别之一是那三个核心需求，
one of the third one, passing on our genetic material, passing on our mind or something about ourselves, a legacy that is in our children. I love my children, having my children some of the best things I've ever done in this world, probably the best thing I've ever done. I remember when my first born came into this world, and I thought, I've tried very hard to be clever in this life and give value and do good things. And nature just made the best thing I've ever done.
第三个，传递我们的遗传物质，传递我们的思想或关于我们自己的东西，一个存在于我们孩子身上的遗产。我爱我的孩子，拥有我的孩子是我在这个世界上做过的最好的事情之一，可能是我做过的最好的事情。我记得当我的第一个孩子来到这个世界上时，我想，我在这辈子非常努力地变得聪明，提供价值，做好的事情。而大自然只是创造了我做过的最好的事情。
Like I didn't have to, my wife did do most of the work. And this wonderful thing came into this world. But maybe what we get legacy-wise is like your podcast, Marian, and putting out things into this world that that's going to live on beyond your years. And we do get to wrestle with this thing. in life which is how do we want to live our life and how do we want it to be what impact do we want to have in this world and i think being a psychologist gives great opportunity in very quiet ways probably ways that most people won't know in ways that we don't want to talk about out loud those many stories that most people have in their in their clinical experience of moments that mattered
就像我不必，我妻子做了大部分工作。而这个美妙的东西来到了这个世界上。但也许我们得到的遗产就像你的播客，玛丽安，把东西放到这个世界上，那将超越你的岁月而存在。我们确实有机会在生活中解决这个问题，那就是我们想如何生活，我们想让它成为什么样，我们想在这个世界上产生什么影响，我认为成为一名心理学家提供了巨大的机会，以非常安静的方式，可能大多数人不会知道的方式，以我们不想大声谈论的方式，那些大多数人在他们的临床经验中拥有的关于重要时刻的故事
those things just get to be passed on good lives and giving value which makes the profession wonderful but it means that is the legacy you get to have as well as your own family yeah my nine year old randomly started crying the other day i wouldn't say he's overly anxious as person but um we're talking about something or watching something and he he said oh oh god i just i just thought that one day you're probably you're probably not going to be you're probably going to die mummy and um i'm just so upset because i how will i ever cope without you um and i and i'm don't say to him, don't be silly, mommy's not going to die. So I don't do what I did to my client in 2020. Instead, I'll say something like, oh, I know, like, oh, I'd be so sad if I did
那些事情只是被传递下去，美好的生活和提供价值，这使得这个职业变得美妙，但这意味着这就是你得到的遗产，以及你自己的家庭。是的，我九岁的孩子前几天随机开始哭，我不会说他是一个过于焦虑的人，但嗯，我们在谈论某事或看某事，他他说，哦，天哪，我只是，我只是想到有一天你可能，你可能不会是，你可能会死，妈妈，而且，我只是太难过了，因为我怎么能没有你而活下去呢？而且我，而且我，不要对他说，别傻了，妈妈不会死的。所以我没有做我在2020年对我的客户做的事情。相反，我会说类似的话，哦，我知道，就像，哦，如果我不得不离开你，我会很难过，我会尽我所能在我过马路前看两边。你知道，我预订了下周的流感疫苗，你知道，我会努力照顾好自己。我去健身房。我，你知道，我吃好的食物。这就是为什么我吃西兰花，你知道，类似的事情。然后他说，是的，是的，我知道。你会照顾好自己的。但其他人呢？如果他们想伤害你怎么办？我说，哦，天哪。是的。这真的很难，不是吗？爱的巨大痛苦是失去。如果我们让自己去爱，我想让我的孩子学会去爱，让我的男孩去爱，但这非常痛苦，没有，没有像
have to leave you, I'm going to do my best to look both ways before I cross the road. You know, I've got my flu jab booked in, you know, next week and, you know, I'm going to try and take good care. I go to the gym. I, you know, I eat good food. This is why I eat my broccoli, you know, stuff like that. And then he's like, yes, yes, I know. You're all going to take good care. But what about everyone else? What if they want to hurt you? And I'm like, oh my goodness. Yeah. It's really hard, isn't it? The great pain of love is loss. If we let ourselves love, and I'd like my child to learn to love and to let herself love my boy but it's incredibly painful there's no there's no pain like
失去你爱的人那样的痛苦，它不像任何其他事情。作为父母，作为亲人，我们能做什么？要富有同情心，要充满爱心。我想，我想正如你所说，我尝试做同样的事情，我和我的女儿谈论损失，但她今年早些时候失去了我的继父，我的祖父，我们昨天举行了追思仪式，所以它非常多地在我们的脑海中，我们确实在以类似的方式谈论它，我们不想做出我们无法兑现的承诺，我会说我之前说过的，我想当我谈论工作时，我想特别是和男人谈话，我想我以这种方式谈论它，即，嗯，生活在我们可以走向黑暗时充满了更多的光明，当我们真正处于
losing someone you love it's not it's not like anything else what can we do as parents as loved ones that be compassionate be loving I think I think as you say I tried to do the same and with my daughter we talk about loss but she lost my stepdad my granddad early this year we had a remembrance ceremony yesterday so it's very much in our heads and we do talk about it a lot in this in a similar way there's no promises we want to make that we can't keep either and i'll say what i said before i think when i talk about work i think particularly talking to men and i think i talk about it in this way that um there is life is so much more full of light when we can go to the darkness and we can appreciate the joys of life when we really are
接触它时，我们可以欣赏生活的乐趣。苦难，我想实际上它们会激发彼此最好的一面。是的，我也这么认为。而且我非常擅长审视黑暗的东西，因为我认为这是我们作为临床心理学家的角色的一部分，我们两个都是，我们需要能够为一个安全的空间提供支持，让人们审视其他人可能会关闭他们的事情。因为它发生得太多了，不是吗？就像，不，不，别担心那个。实际上，哦，我很抱歉你担心那个。就像，你认为那与什么有关，或者你的恐惧是什么？你知道，我有一件事，我和客户做，我们不断挖掘，然后呢，然后呢，然后呢，然后呢，然后呢，然后呢，然后它会像，好吧，我会死在地板上，我的孩子们将不得不，你知道，想出该怎么办，或者其他什么，而且就像，就像你说的，总有一个原因在推动我们的行为，我真的很喜欢你说的功能语境主义的想法，我以前没听说过，但我喜欢那个，我认为你应该写一本关于那个的书，马特，是的，就像迷人的
in contact with it suffering i think actually they bring out the best in each other Yeah, I think so too. And I'm all right at looking at the dark stuff because I think that's part of our role as clinical psychologists, both of us are, is that we need to be able to hold a safe space for people to look at things that other people might shut them down about. Because it happens so much, doesn't it? Like, no, no, don't worry about that. And it's actually, oh, I'm sorry to you are worried about that. Like, what do you think that's linked to or what would be your fear? You know, I have this thing that I do with clients that we keep digging and then what and then what and then what and then what and then what and then what and then it'll be like well I'll be dead on the floor and my children will have to you know work out what to do or whatever and there's like like you said there's always a reason that is fueling our behaviour and I really love the idea of the kind of functional functional contextualism you said about I haven't heard of that before but I love that I think you should write a book on that Matt yeah like fascinating
东西。而且，是的，就像我们将要谈论的，在我们将要录制的另一集里，我们将谈论抚养男孩，让他们不要陷入那种厌女的叙事，并尝试尝试，我不知道，培养好的公民。作为一个男孩的母亲，我思考这个问题。所以如果有人非常喜欢我们的谈话，他们可能也会非常喜欢接下来的谈话。马特，有什么你想留给我们但我们没有涵盖的吗？我们将谈到你的社交媒体在哪里，人们应该在哪里关注你，但有什么我们没有涵盖的，你认为我们的听众应该注意的吗？
stuff. And yeah, like we're going to talk about, in another episode that we're going to record shortly, we're going to talk about raising boys to not kind of fall into the whole kind of misogynistic narratives and to try to try to kind of, I don't know, raise good citizens. That's something that I think about as a mother of boys. So if anyone has really enjoyed our conversation, they might well really love the conversation that's coming next to. Matt, is there anything that you wanted to leave us with that we haven't covered? We will come to where your socials are and where people should follow you, but is there anything we haven't covered that you think that our audience should be mindful of?
也许我会留下这个，即当你，如果你从事心理健康行业，如果你对这个感兴趣，并且你在思考你自己或他人，这种帮助人们在没有羞耻感的情况下理解的框架，羞耻感对我们的任何经历从来都不是好事，更多关于这来自哪里的同情心。我们也可以有更多的工具来处理我们的古老，我会称这些为我们的古老生存策略，它们出现在现代世界，在诊断下，无论是战斗、逃跑、冻结、瘫倒、讨好、假装，任何这些出现的东西。以及我们如何生活，我们，我关于这个的两个伟大的智慧，我从别人那里学到的，是自我意识和处理那些困难时刻出现的事情的技能，这两个部分是帮助人们过上他们想要的生活的伟大钥匙。这就是我在我的工作中尝试做的，也许也是你可以尝试做的。非常感谢你，马特。人们在哪里可以找到更多关于你和你工作的信息？
Maybe I'll leave with this, is that when you're, if you're in a mental health profession, If you're interested in this and you're thinking about yourself or others, that this frame of helping people understand without shame, shame is never good for any of our experiences, more compassion about where this comes from. We can also have more tools to deal with our ancient, I will call these our ancient survival strategies that show up a modern day world under diagnosis, where it's fight, flight, freeze, flop, fawn, feign, any of these things that turn up. and how we live our lives, we can, my two great pieces of wisdom on this, what I've learned from others, is that self-awareness and the skills to deal with what comes up in those difficult moments, those two pieces are the great keys to helping people live the lives they want. That's what I try and do in my work, maybe what you can try and do too. Thank you so much, Matt. Where can people find out more about you and your work?
也许我想以这一点作为结束：如果你从事心理健康行业，或者你对这个领域感兴趣，并且正在思考自己或他人，那么这种帮助人们在没有羞耻感的情况下理解问题的框架非常重要。羞耻感对我们的任何经历都毫无益处，我们应该对这些问题的根源抱有更多的同情心。我们也可以拥有更多的工具来应对我们古老的生存策略——我称之为古老的生存策略——它们在现代世界中表现为各种诊断，无论是战斗、逃跑、僵住、瘫痪、讨好、伪装，还是任何其他表现形式。关于我们如何生活，我从他人那里学到的两条伟大的智慧是：自我意识以及应对困难时刻所出现问题的技能，这两点是帮助人们过上他们想要的生活的关键。这就是我在工作中努力做的事情，也许你也可以尝试这样做。非常感谢你，马特。人们可以在哪里了解更多关于你和你工作的信息？
They can go to my website, Dr Matt Slavin.com, or find me on socials. I'm on LinkedIn under Dr. Matt Slavin or Instagram. You can Google my name or my handle mental.advantage. Lovely. And for anyone that's listening rather than watching, I will just spell Slavin. It's S-L-A-V-I-N. Thank you so much for your time. Everything that we've mentioned that is linkable will be linked.
他们可以访问我的网站 Dr Matt Slavin.com，或者在社交媒体上找到我。我在 LinkedIn 上的名字是 Dr. Matt Slavin，Instagram 上也有。你可以谷歌搜索我的名字或我的账号 mental.advantage。太好了。对于那些只听音频而不看视频的听众，我拼写一下 Slavin，是 S-L-A-V-I-N。非常感谢你抽出时间。我们提到的所有可以链接的内容都会放在链接里。
in the description or the show notes. Thanks for your time, Matt, and I'll look forward to our next episode coming very soon. Thank you so much. Thank you once again to our incredible guest, Dr. Matt Slavin. And there will be another episode coming with Matt next week, and I can promise you that's also a brilliant one too. Yeah, so maybe click Notify if you're watching on YouTube
在描述或节目笔记中。谢谢你的时间，Matt，我很期待我们很快推出的下一集。非常感谢。再次感谢我们出色的嘉宾 Matt Slavin 博士。下周还会有另一集关于 Matt 的节目，我保证那也会非常精彩。是的，如果你在 YouTube 上观看，可以点击通知按钮，
and then you will be told when that episode lands and then you will never miss another episode either. Please do consider joining his mailing list. I am absolutely going to be doing that in a moment too. If you love this conversation and you would like to think about how you can kind of introduce some of the tricky brain theory into your work with clients, well, I've thought of that. We've got the tricky brain psycho education kit, which you can use for people who are experiencing depression, grief and trauma. It comes with an online course as well where you can learn how to deliver it in kind of Marianne's style. And you can grab an exclusive £10 off that kit by going to my website www. Aspiring hyphen psychologist.co.com.uk.
这样当那一集发布时你就会收到通知，你就不会错过任何一集了。请考虑加入他的邮件列表。我待会儿也绝对会这样做。如果你喜欢这次谈话，并且想考虑如何将一些“棘手大脑”理论引入到你与客户的工作中，我已经为你考虑到了。我们有“棘手大脑”心理教育工具包，你可以将其用于经历抑郁、悲伤和创伤的人群。它还附带一门在线课程，你可以学习如何以 Marianne 的风格进行讲解。你可以通过访问我的网站 www.aspiringpsychologist.co.uk 获取该工具包 10 英镑的独家折扣。
Click, I think it's learn with me along the top and then the Our Tricky Brain Kit. And then the code in capital letters is YouTube 10. then you can grab your £10 off and that will be delivered to you wherever you happen to be. So, yeah, thank you again for being part of my world. If you would like to check out the brand new project, which I've unveiled on YouTube and Spotify and Apple, it's a way of helping me to know that you really value the content I create. And it's kind of a bit like a Patreon, but it's you subscribing to be a paid subscriber where you're then get some exclusive behind the scenes episodes.
点击顶部菜单栏的“跟我学习”，然后找到“我们的棘手大脑工具包”。使用大写字母代码 YouTube 10，你就可以获得 10 英镑的折扣，无论你在哪里，它都会送到你手中。再次感谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你想查看我在 YouTube、Spotify 和 Apple 上推出的全新项目，这是一种让我知道你非常重视我所创作内容的方式。它有点像 Patreon，但你是通过订阅成为付费订阅者，从而获得一些独家的幕后花絮。
So at the moment there's one behind the scenes episode per episode of the podcast. As it evolves, there might well become more subscriber content, but I pledge to you, the main podcast itself, will always remain free to you guys. But this is just to help support my costs and just for me to know that you really value and rate the content that I provide. please do check out the details in the show notes or if you've got any questions about it drop me a memo on social media which you can do where I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere with Dr. Mary and Trent. Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton.
目前，播客的每一集都有一个幕后花絮。随着它的发展，未来可能会有更多的订阅者内容，但我向你们保证，主播客本身将永远对你们免费。但这只是为了帮助我分担成本，也让我知道你确实重视和认可我提供的内容。请查看节目笔记中的详细信息，或者如果你有任何问题，可以在社交媒体上给我留言，我在所有平台上都是 Dr. Marianne Trent。嗨，我叫 Emily。我是南安普顿大学临床心理学专业的硕士生。
I bought the book of the Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications, and I'm so glad I did. seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills. It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get onto the doctorate this year, that's okay. I think the most unexpected pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational each and every person's journey was. And using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure. I'm almost reluctant to come to the end. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我买了《临床心理学家集体》这本书来帮助自己准备第一轮博士申请，我很高兴我这么做了。看到其他人如何反思他们的旅程非常有启发性，这让我对自己的人生旅程和技能有了很多思考。它还有助于让我以正确的视角看待事物，并提醒我，如果今年没能考上博士也没关系。然而，这本书最意想不到的乐趣在于每个人的旅程是多么鼓舞人心。每天早上用这些故事作为我的动力真是一种享受。我几乎舍不得读完它。这一集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。